- My mother was a witch.
And I know that I said my
favorite of her sayings
was the one about the
bloated monk who feared
his vow of silence
covered farts,
but I didn't have a
way with the phrase.
I'm afraid that
I'll word it wrong.
Tell it another
time, [inaudible]..
The woods reward silence.
It is in the silence we hear
things not of this world.
Now, I will show you.
You must step very carefully.
Here to here.
Are you nervous of
what you will find
when you reach [inaudible]?
Perhaps.
Which means you [inaudible]
as surprise as [inaudible]..
[gasps]
Ah.
[laughs] It's fine.
[sighs]
They are everywhere on
[inaudible] this time of year.
And there are mice, of
course, many hawks, which also
eat the mice but prefer
to eat the snakes
and sometimes get both.
There is also another
creature, the [inaudible]..
The child of my
housekeeper, Mary.
This is one of the surprises
I will warn you of now.
You have a housekeeper?
I depend on her as she
is a [inaudible] woman.
And she may test you.
She may throw curses at you.
Then you must put
her in her place.
She has long since forgotten
her place, I'm afraid.
Come.
I will tell you the
story of the wasp
that followed me for two days.
Yes.
I looked and saw--